hey youtubers it's Charlie so I wanted
to do a special bonus video explaining
Tower of joy Lyanna stark Jon Snow stuff
a lot of people were wondering why they
didn't explain what was going on with
Jon Snow's true father so just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the TV show and we're going
to be digging into some of the book
stuff that the TV show has done so there
are a couple big things happening when
they do this big flashback there a
couple big reasons why they did it this
way one they wanted to show you who Jon
Snow's mother was without explicitly
explaining his father because I think
they're gonna save that for a future
season so that's one of the biggest
reasons why she's whispering to Ned and
why it's all muffled and people are like
did she say Jo Harris is that Jon Snow's
true name is he have a Targaryen name in
mysteriously or maybe not so
mysteriously a lot of people were like R
plus L equals J means Robert plus Liana
equals Jon and you can kind of see all
the book readers in the background
summoning pictures of the little bear
just going nope absolutely not Rhaegar
Targaryen plus Lyanna Stark equals Jon
Snow so it should come as no surprise
that they don't want to give you all the
information about Jon Snow's backstory
right away they just want to tease it
out like when we first saw the Tower of
joy we heard the woman's scream and the
three-eyed Raven stops bran short before
he can go see the rest of the scene til
the end of the season they wanted to
withhold that information now there's a
very important reason that brain is
flashing back to Jon Snow's birth that
I'll probably talk about in another
video because that's a Zora hi related
that's a completely separate thing this
is mostly about Rhaegar Targaryen his
father so this season was all about
revealing who his true mother was
because remember that was the first big
tease we got in season 1 is my mother
still alive does she know about me and
know Ned Stark's like we'll talk about
your mother the next time we meet but
that moment never came then we get to
season 6 and we slowly start learning
about Lyanna stark father never talked
about her we see her showing off on a
horse we see Ned Stark getting ready to
go to the Vale that's basically where he
was raised he was raised by Jon Arryn
with Robert Baratheon that's where they
became good friends so then in the next
flashback we jump way forward in time to
the very end of Robert's rebellion
Rhaegar Targaryen has already died at
the Battle of the Trident Ned Stark
shows up at the Tower of joy in Dorne
with Howland Reed in a couple of his
other best men saying we're
my sister and we have two of the
greatest Kingsguard in the realm and if
you've only been watching the show you
haven't read the books of the expanded
material or anything like that you don't
really realize who these people are like
why it is they're wearing targeted
jewels what Kingsguard represent in why
they would be guarding all these people
at the Tower of joy they kind of did a
good job of that visually when Arthur
Dayne just completely lays out all those
people and they just narrowly gets
killed by Howland Reed with a backstab
but these two people were part of
Rhaegar Targaryen personal Kingsguard
Arthur Dayne was one of his best friends
he was also the best most deadly fighter
in the kingdom but what had happened is
is during Robert's rebellion Rhaegar had
absconded with Lyanna stark for unknown
reasons like that's the part that
they've still left out that they'll fill
out in later seasons but Rhaegar took
her to the Tower of joy with these
Kingsguard
but then he was called away to fight in
the Battle of the Trident he's the crown
prince so he has to lead the force like
he was forced to leave the Tower of joy
so in this flashback Ned Stark has that
comment where he's like we looked for
you at the Trident that's where Rhaegar
died where Robert killed Rhaegar Arthur
Dayne says we weren't there we were here
so it's basically Arthur Dayne saying
had we been at the Battle of the Trident
we probably would have won your side
would have lost so why would Rhaegar
have left a weapon of mass destruction
Kingsguard back here to guard Leone a
stark probably because Kingsguard only
guard future Kings as in the baby Jon
Snow so the idea is is that the
Kingsguard were at that Tower not to
protect Lyanna stark but there's a whole
bunch of backstory that they have to
fill enough a bunch of logic they have
to fill before Jon Snow can become an
official crown prince
so more backstory Targaryen z' were
known to take multiple wives they went
brother to sister they did all kinds of
crazy marriage things so what it seems
like the books in the show is telling us
is that Rhaegar married Lyanna stark on
the side while he was also married to
Elia Martell and then had this baby Jon
Snow with her making him another Crown
Prince not the firstborn Crown Prince to
Rhaegar remember Rhaegar had other
children with Elia Martell but they all
died in the siege of King's Landing at
the end of Robert
Balian so that's a whole lot of
information that says nothing about
about the secret Nate like does he have
a Targaryen aim is it Joe Harris
so naturally the TV show would want to
save some of those big reveals
explaining those things for future
seasons so we'll probably continue to
see this story play out in brand
flashbacks and what it effectively is is
like a Romeo and Juliet type story told
in past tense so you get all these
pieces of information like Littlefinger
tells Santa about how Rhaegar was in
love with Lyanna Stark
crowned her the tourney of Harrenhal
that will probably be one of the big
flashbacks that we see in future seasons
so all these flashbacks share something
in common they tell the story of
Robert's rebellion Lyanna Stark Ned
Stark Jon Snow in Rhaegar Targaryen but
we haven't seen Rhaegar Targaryen at all
yet because like I said this season was
more about revealing who Jon Snow's
mother was I think future seasons will
reveal his father so flashbacks to hype
in the future tourney and Harrenhal
knight of the Laughing tree which is
kind of a Lyanna stark moment and in the
Battle of the Trident the Battle of the
Trident was basically the moment of
rygaards death so it's basically giving
you romeo-juliet Game of Thrones in
flashbacks but we've got two more
seasons to fill that out at least so yay
for flashbacks yay for secret Targaryen
Jon Snow but the other big thing the HBO
did on it's making Game of Thrones
website like this is an official image
it shows character relationships like
who you know who's a mother who's a
friend and it shows Rhaegar Targaryen is
Jon Snow's father so if you've been
reading the books you've probably
thought this for a long time but if
you've only watched the TV show then
you've only just started to get clue so
I totally understand if you didn't
really understand the Rhaegar part of
this or why they didn't show who his
father was
they want to save that information for
future season and show it to you
visually like they showed the the Jon
Snow baby transition so whatever ends up
happening it'll be very cinematic I
can't wait to see attorney at harrenhal
flashback I will be a little upset if
they skip over that usually the big
moments that they talk about characters
talk about something really big
happening they show you in flashback
like we heard Jamie's story about what
the Mad King tried to do to King's
Landing burn it down with wildfire then
three seasons later we finally get to
see it in a flashback so if a character
has told a story about something
happening in the past like Littlefinger
talking
attorney of harrenhal I think that means
that the show is going to pay that off
but about the name the reason the people
think that jon snow's name might be joe
harris because he would be half
Targaryen and re listening to this
moment you know people have said it
sounds like a just sound so the reason
why people are like maybe his name is
joe harris is because there's a certain
naming scheme with kings in the past
that repeats itself like Daenerys his
father is called the Mad King
there's Aegon the conquerer who Daenerys
his story is kind of mirroring right now
there was Bale or the blessed and then
there was Joe Harris the wise the king
that came before him was called maegor
the cruel who sounds a lot like the Mad
King so a lot of people were like maybe
George R Martin intended this you know
to be cyclical in this way wherein
Rhaegar has a baby and recognizing that
his father as a terrible king wants to
get rid of him and maybe Rhaegar named
John snow joe harris as a way to instill
his hope for the future in him like the
new j harris the wise following maegor
the cruel but obviously didn't go that
way but don't you think it's interesting
now that Jon Snow has become a king in
his own right through his own actions
rather than just by birth like he's been
named king despite being a bastard by
all these people in the north so really
the show is just telling you that Jon
Snow is a very special person which you
already knew but there's a whole bunch
of stuff we can talk about depending on
the new flashbacks that they do in
future seasons like the fact that
Rhaegar was trying to depose the Mad
King using a great counsel that was all
part of a plan involving the tourney at
Harrenhal so not only is the tourney of
Harrenhal like a really big Leon a stark
Rhaegar Targaryen moment there's also a
lot of political things that were
happening at that so that's why I think
that'll be one of the future flashbacks
but let me know in the comments how long
do you think the show will wait before
we see Rhaegar Targaryen in a flashback
just listen for casting notes for an
actor who's very handsome who can sing
while talking because Rhaegar was like a
big singer he was kind of like a bard
who was really good with a sword so we
need someone who's super charismatic who
can sing while he's walking around and
is a good enough fighter to beat
everyone else in the realm in a giant
tournament because Rhaegar won the
tourney of Harrenhal in almost the
entire realm was there so it's funny how
like when you pick up with the show you
hear the Targaryen sand they're supposed
to be really evil but then because
while these flashbacks and because of
Daenerys you know that it's not that
simple history is always more
complicated than what people make it
seem that's kind of a little finger idea
like little fingers the one giving
thoughts of this information little
finger also a very complicated person
not really evil but not a good person
either so when does everyone feel like
we're finally going to see Rhaegar
Targaryen my hope is is that we see it
relatively early in season seven but
they could also say that like they save
the Lyanna stark Jon Snow mother
revealed for the very end of season six
they could do the same thing with
Rhaegar for Season seven but of course
the show will eventually show you who
Jon Snow's father is it'll be very
explicit like oh this is very clearly
his father he and Lyanna Stark were very
clearly in love and then we also have
this war for the dawn that's kind of
like a season 8 thing I feel like we're
getting the information on Jon Snow's
family first then we'll get like larger
war for the dawn context so we learn who
his mother is then we'll learn about his
father then we'll learn why people think
that he's a prophecy child the Ozora
high child born under the bleeding star
but that's all stuff for future videos
so we'll have all kinds of bonus videos
and we also have to talk a lot about
Cersei Cersei is going to be so much fun
in future seasons so a lot of Cersei
Ozora hi Jon Snow Lyanna Stark we can
keep talking about them all summer so
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Steve wonders you
win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details that's just on the about page so
Q&A just postponed till tomorrow so I
will do my Q&A tomorrow and there is a
new round of the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video just a whole
bunch of Game of Thrones giveaways this
week because I'm so happy with the way
the season went down so get hype so why
you guys wait for me to post that next
video you can click here for my season 7
predictions and you can click here for
my episode 10 finale video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you